and on the mound today for your detroit
tigers will be derek skubal
well we know this about terry school but
he loves that fastball it'll sit in the
mid 90s he's also got a curve ball and a
slider he likes to crisscross the strike
zone he'll cut that slider down in the
back foot of the righties and away from
the left-handers he also likes to work
north and south shelf he's going to work
north with the fastball and then he'll
work the bottom of the zone with that
nasty slider that he's featured
strikes out hernandez to start the day
in control drives one to right field
victor reyes is there
the 2-2 that's a good start for derrick
school
down goal the red sox one two three that
only happened once last night
scoobles already done it here once this
afternoon it is martin perez in his 22nd
start of the season yeah the heat is on
for martine to have a nice game he's
been scuffling the last four starts
giving up seven home runs how he's gone
he's gone real good and he goes real bad
he needs a real good one today
robbie grossman the lead off spot
oh two to grossman drives one deep left
field verdugo looks up that ball is out
of here
what a way to start today
robbie grossman there on an 02 count he
can let that ball get a little bit
deeper but yet still catching it out
front especially from the left-hander
and robbie gets himself gets that high
he's got a high leg kick gets it up
early fastball love that he can handle
and boy does he put a good swing on this
take a look at the rhythm see the time
in the front foot gets down then watch
the back side explode through this
baseball here and that's why robbie knew
right away she go here to victor reyes
to lead off the second
drive to deep left center field that's
going to get up the alley
reyes hits the bag at second he wants
three he's there with a head first slide
a lead off triple here in the second for
victor reyes the 2-2
just like that just like that to center
field hernandez
way back there
zach short gets it done
unselfish at bat
takes a 2-2 pitch to center it's a
sacrifice fly
brings home victor reyes two-nothing
tigers
on the ground in the hole to the left
side
willie castro will challenge all the way
to third he's in there and hill moves up
to second base
aggressive base running paying off for
the tigers here in the second and that's
exactly
what this offense is doing take a look
here at willy castro maybe not the ideal
situation for the goal the ball's right
in front of him but he takes off running
because he believes he can make it but
then how about the back end there too
look at him he's reading recognizes okay
i've got an opportunity to take a chance
here and put some pressure on the left
fielder to make a play
oh it hit him
the bases are juiced with 208 phillips
valdez is in for boston
scope taps one in front valdez can't get
him at home
so he goes to first base and gets scoped
by a step
[Applause]
so another run played it for the tigers
3-2 again got him swinging with the
chain jump
big out for valdez to second and third
now for jd martinez
he rings him up
95 on the inside corner jd martinez sits
down two away the 2-2
curveball fly ball center field hill on
the run tracking and he'll make the
catch in deep straight away center what
a job by terek skubal but it was a
second and third one out jamie does not
allow one to score 2-2
on the ground sliding stab by bogarts to
throw out short
nicely done by xander
hogie doesn't have that far to go with
it but goes into a slide on one knee
makes the play look fairly easy
that ball was sharply hit
school's been
pitching with runners in scoring
position now in four consecutive innings
another 3-2 to devers
popped it up
hill is under it he's got it
another key out for tarik skubal against
a really good hit or two away there's
the payoff
in the air to right field
victor reyes is under it he's got it and
tarek skubal gets out of another jam how
about that
what a job by the tigers rookie lefty
two on two outs bottom of the fifth
three nothing tigers opens the door for
jamer candelario 3-1 on its way fly ball
deep center field hernandez going back
that ball is over his head and into the
bushes
off a bounce that's a ground rule double
for jamer candelario
scope scores cabrera will have to go
back to third
jamer candelario pads the tigers lead
it's four nothing runners at second and
third for victor reyes
fly ball deep to center field off the
bat of reyes that's going to split the
outfielders out of the way the deepest
part of the ballpark in right center
cabrera's in behind him candelario reyes
to third with his second triple of the
day goes in standing up
two run triple six nothing tigers in the
fish
i like him even more today nice play by
jonathan scope from his knees and they
retire kevin plowecki do it scope
that's good communication that's good
trust
with darwin's in
here's his smash
in the left field diving play by verdugo
he picked that one off the turf
no quit in alex verdugo very nice play
out there very athletic play that's a
line drive sinking fast headlong dive
nicely done
that's as good as it gets
scopes singled and scored as last time
the 2-2 that's a base hitch
but due will score with ease jonathan
scope and aquilma new tag team for
another tigers run
very likable guy here
fly ball deep center field
hill circles it and that's a winning
home stand and a winning series
for the tigers
they blow up the red sox 8-1
a feel-good decision on a thursday
afternoon in detroit
you